but a nice week guys so bianca's talking
about halloween
and i think a lot of people are in the
spirit already i've seen a lot of
decorations that are out in the
neighborhoods
and it's going to feel a little more
fall-like by the end of the week we've
got beautiful skies out there that sun
is
up got some high clouds moving in
sunrise officially at 6 39
6 18 is the sunset so boy it's just
getting dark
earlier and earlier just so you can feel
it lots of 60s out there around the las
vegas valley still some low 70s in the
northwest
we've got 68 at aliante though north las
vegas in the 60s nellis has been the
coolest spot this morning
in the mid 60s lots of upper 60s from
sunrise mountain to anthem to
mountains edge this morning so enjoy
these mornings those are always
the coolest temps that we get right at
daybreak so a red rock in the 60s this
morning sorry the number just fell off
there but
probably long sleeves a good idea if
you're going to get out there early 57
in kingman 59
in perron 168 days no rainfall for us
it is really a long dry spell we'll
start off the week with 90s
we'll have periods of cloud and clouds
and wind and then we're on our way to
some
cooler temperatures oh if we can get
some rain from this big system moving in
that's way
out in the pacific it's going to take
just about all week for it to get here
and just ease this high pressure out of
the way
it looks like a lot of the west will get
some rain but i think most of it's going
to stay to the north of southern nevada
we'll stay dry we'll have these high
clouds around and they won't hold back
the extra heat today
upper 90s again just like the weekend
our normal high is 86.
we'll be well above that as we get
through the first part of the week
97 today and tomorrow clouds move out
we'll have plenty of sun tuesday
wednesday more clouds
later in the week by thursday lots of
wind so we'll have
periods of clouds and wind some energy
riding on this trough of low pressure
that's going to set up across the west
and eventually it breaks down that heat
brings us 80's for highs
even low 80's sunday and mornings i
think we're going to drop into the very
fall like 50's
by the weekend